Louise Hay and joins us now for Labor's
take on the ongoing strikes crisis
across the public sector and transport
Network I know you were tweeting about
the grant chaps photo earlier this week
as well thing that's ever happened
you've taken the photo down my favorite
thing was that he actually forgot to
photoshop out Boris Johnson's elbow that
was still uh showing in the video
onto more uh serious uh matters uh the
rail strikes what did you make of Mark
Harper's interview I don't know if you
caught much of it well I I think it's
incredibly frustrating that here we are
six months after
um the strikes have started this dispute
has been rumbling on for all these
months and we're still hearing
um the same old rhetoric from the
transport secretary they started when
grunt shops were still my opposite
number and even back then when they
started it was clear to everyone in the
industry and in the public that nothing
could happen with this dispute that the
operators and network rail couldn't lift
a finger without the transport secretary
or the treasury's
um influence and these negotiations
simply can't be brought to a resolution
until the transfer secretary does his
job grows up and sits down at the
negotiating table with the with the
operators because as you rightly pointed
out post covered we now have this system
where operators get a fixed fee
regardless of whether their trains run
so they have absolutely no incentive
whatsoever to settle this dispute so
what exactly what Mark Harper is doing
is talking to them right which is what
Grant shops didn't do but Mark Harper is
actually now talking to the union bosses
so what would you do differently you
know if you were the transport secretary
if you were sitting down around the
table what happened then well we've got
a better tone from Mark Harper than
Grant chaps there's no there's no doubt
about that but there's worlds apart from
getting in the unions for a cup of tea
in the department for transport and
actually sitting down and doing the hard
graft of negotiation what is what is
your starting point from a negotiation
then well the negotiation is about a
whole raft of things we've got pay we've
got conditions we've got jobs and that
needs to be done actually as part of a
wider conversation about reform in the
rail industry and that's part of the
problem that's part of the reason why
the dispute is rumbling on longer than
it should because it's happening in this
completely unreformed and quite frankly
failing rail system where operators are
being given a fee regardless of whether
their trains run and you've got a system
where the likes of Avanti and Transplant
and express are not delivering the
service that are required of them not
investing in the workforce as they have
been asked to do time and time again
over very many years and it's a a
feature and a failure of the very
short-term nature of the rail industry
so labor have a plan to bring our
Railways back into public ownership to
reform the system to put passengers back
at the heart and frankly reset
industrial relations so we can bring
this cycle of very disruptive disputes
to an end you obviously do want reform
the nationalization project but minus
some things that would only happen when
contracts expire so will be some years
away even if labor do again into power
so I'm kind of interested in the here
and now do you think that rail fares are
too expensive right now well first have
risen far faster than uh than wages over
the last 10 years they've risen faster
than fuel as well uh so the rail is is
unaffordable so far too many people if
it is unaffordable then what would you
do because at the minute you know the
the people working the railways want
more money they're resisting reforms uh
that would for example uh lead to driver
uh operated trains which would
potentially reduce costs as well and
obviously there is this taxpayer subsidy
as well that you've raised points about
so where where does the savings come if
you want to make welfare more cheap well
look there needs to be investment in the
in the rail service it's undeniable and
the fact that that was investment
through covid to keep it going doesn't
deny the fact that um there are issues
with pay
um now you know there needs to be that
wider reform and actually the vast
majority of franchises will come up in
the first uh for expiration in the first
first term of a labor government a lot
are already being run uh by the operator
of Last Resort so it's not the case that
this would be very far in the future
there needs to be that widespread reform
and the fact is the amount that they
wanted to save through the workplace
reforms that they're trying to push
through have already been far eclipsed
from the damage that these tracks have
done to the economy over the last six
months so the intransigence and the
ham-fisted approach that this government
has taken to this dispute is costing the
economy and the entire rail industry
dear
um just finally
um should we care if the prime
minister's had private healthcare
I think I mean we want the prime
minister to be honest about it which he
failed to be at the weekend and only
just corrected um today but I think what
it gets to the heart of is because the
NHS is in such crisis because we have
record waiting lists with over seven
million people waiting for Health Care
it has effectively created a two-tier
health system which means that a lot of
people can't afford aren't able to
access Healthcare aren't able to access
a GP appointment and can't get into a e
and it does mean that the well-off can
afford Private health care and if that's
the case with the Prime Minister
um then he should be honest about it and
it does reveal something that he doesn't
isn't necessarily experiencing the very
poor Healthcare that a lot of people
across the country are okay thank you
very much for being on the program uh
Lou at